[Music]  this is Margarita Island where locals  are hit by decades-long economic  struggles in Venezuela here harvesting  salt has become a new way to make money  [Music]  the Salt Ponds of pompatar were once  just considered a playground for kids  now those kids help their Elders collect  salt to sell to fishermen cheese makers  and wholesalers Jose Gutierrez was a  manager at a grocery store but lost his  job during the pandemic  the dollar is the go-to currency in the  country now and the going price for this  salt is 2 cents per pound despite  working many hours per day basic  necessities are pricey for these workers  [Music]  tourism accounts for the majority of the  Island's economy but in Venezuela's  uneven recovery many are taking  advantage of any resource to make ends  meet  foreign